some claim that one of the unsung heroes
of True Detective is actress Alexandra
Daddario as the character Lisa a court
stenographer and Marty heart's mistress
in 1995. while leaves from Marty's
secret affair becomes increasingly toxic
the Dario brings genuine empathy
complexity and death to a character who
easily could have been written off as
superficial go away I'll
oh
however her character being highly
sexualized led to the Dario's
apprehension about filming her first
ever nude scenes for the show according
to a 2014 interview with MTV the actress
explains just how difficult it was to
prepare herself for her scene I really
wanted to be a part of the show and I
understood why the nudity in all of that
was required of the character the
character is really different from
anything that I've done before the
nudity was just part of that fortunately
the Dario claimed that the cast and crew
held Porter at ease with halson in
particular making the whole interaction
very comfortable for her